ginger strand explores the history of
Niagara Falls and argues that the Falls
are now more a man-made creation and
less a product of nature the event
hosted by the book corner bookstore in
Niagara Falls New York is 50 minutes
thank you very much to the book corner
and the Morrow family and to all of you
for coming today it's it's almost
overwhelming to be coming back to
Niagara Falls and reading from this
project which has been a long time in
the making and it's it's exceptionally
thrilling to see so many of the faces
the familiar faces of the people who've
helped me throughout this long and
arduous process and whose stories and
whose characters are so much a part of
this book when I dedicated the book to
the people of the Niagara region it
wasn't just a sort of you know
last-minute thing I really felt as if
without all of you in all of your
stories it the book couldn't possibly
exist at all and people were so generous
and sharing them with me I wish I could
have heard everyone's stories but at a
certain point my editor told me I had to
stop writing so I will confess to a
little bit of wondering about what to
read in Niagara Falls because much of
what's in my book I think is news to
people across the nation and it's not so
much news to the people of Niagara who
live here and really understand the
intricacies of the power project and
know a lot about the regional history in
fact I've never been in a region with so
many well-informed regional historians
and I think that's probably because you
guys have so much fascinating history to
look into that you can spend a lifetime
doing it I decided to read from my
chapter the other side of Jordan which
deals with one of the more familiar
stories of Niagara Falls the story of
Blondin and his tightrope ascensions but
I thought that it came at it from a
different
approach than that of any of the
previous writers about it so I thought
it might be interesting for you folks
today and also there are many good
images to go with it so I put together
some slides which I hope you'll be able
to see and enjoy
imagine Harry Colcord looking at the
rope
he helped string it across the Niagara
Gorge now it stretches out before him
two inches thick and sloping downward in
such a steep curve it looks as if it
dips into the river below between Harry
and the rope stands a small muscular man
five feet five inches tall and around
130 pounds
Harry weighs 136 it's a hot summer day
in 1859 alright someone says Harry puts
one foot in the leather stirrup hanging
from a harness over the man's shoulder
and steps up he puts his arms around the
man's chest
he remembers how he once thought that
after whaling theatrical management
would seem tame you are dead weight the
man tells Harry and a thick French
accent if I sway or stumble do not try
to balance you are not cold cord you are
blonde and then Blondin steps onto the
tightrope it's like jumping off a cliff
there's a sound almost like the rustle
of wind as the crowd lining the bank
behind them collectively draws its
breath blonde and moves forward one foot
than the other
the Rope sways Harry thinks of the sea
Blondin told you not to look down but he
does beneath them 190 feet of windy air
than a rushing river from which no one
emerges alive a tiny boat Bob's like a
toy on the water below crammed with
faces turned upward waiting to see them
drop the sound of the wind the sound of
Niagara Falls one foot than the other
foot
don't move Harry tells himself he
concentrates on blonde and pole it
weighs 40 pounds he's lifted it when the
two of them go right the pole goes left
Harry stares at the pole and imagines he
is that pole leaning left the wind picks
up and the tails of his morning jackets
laugh against the back of his legs
he imagines melting he can feel a heart
pounding against blonde goons back and
he doesn't know if it's blonde ins or
his after a while a kind of calm takes
over Harry is entirely focused on
staying limp he doesn't hear the Falls
anymore and then Blondin stops get off
he says get off the stocky man beneath
him is the only thing between him and a
fatal fall and he wants Harry off it's
tough work reoffending the steep hill to
the other bank even without a man on
your back Harry knows blond and must
rest he can't get down he has to Harry
slides one foot out of the stirrup and
reaches it toward what he can't breathe
then his toe taps the Rope it's
vibrating in the wind
he sets one foot on that vibration his
hands clutched Blondin shoulders he
slides the other foot out of its stirrup
and brings it down next to the first he
stares at blond uns back rising and
falling if he loses his nerve he will
die
after what seems like an endless time
blonde and says get back on Harry does
and they move forward one foot than the
other this happens five times the
crossing takes 42 minutes the sky the
Falls the green river below after a
while Harry sees none of it just blonde
and back and the beads of sweat on the
back of blonde um's neck but at the end
he looks up and sees a dark mass of
people lining the banks a nearby bridge
he sees thousands of eyes wide with
something almost like horror some of
them hold out their hands Colcord is not
in that slide but you can see these
spectators on the right lining the bank
Blondin stops and for the first time
Harry feels him hesitate both men see
the danger of the crowd it's eagerness
could knock them off the rope at the
very end they freeze staring at the sea
of faces no one moves what should I do
blonde and asks make a rush and drive
right through them Harry says he's
surprised to hear his voice sounding so
low and calm Blondin tightens his grip
on the pole then they're moving fast
shoving through a sea of hands and
cases hairy seas ladies weeping
gentlemen pressing coins into his hand
children lost it above the fray to see
him and he realizes he's made it he's
going to be rich now I want you to
imagine another young man the same age
as Colcord late 20s and with a similar
physique small but muscular well used to
hard work the setting is the same a
Niagara River the man is crossing in the
other direction from the United States
to Canada
this time it is dark there are no eyes
upon him the person holding his hand is
a woman but she's such a powerful woman
people call her Moses she and the man
are both absolutely silent they are not
on a rope but on the suspension bridge
less than 50 yards downstream from the
wire blonde and crosses by day this man
can also feel his heart pounding if he
loses his nerve he too will die not
because he will fall but because Harriet
Tubman will shoot him silent and swift
Harriet leads the way as she's done
dozens of times when they arrived on the
other side the man drops to his knees
and puts his handle on the ground as if
he expects it to reach out and embrace
him he's made it he is going to be free
people are fascinated by Niagara stunts
earth whenever I mentioned my Niagara
obsession people almost inevitably bring
up honeymoon honeymoons or Daredevils Oh
Niagara you mean like people going over
it in barrels no I usually say try not
to sound like a snob the history even
when I'm at the Falls I tend to glance
only briefly at the Daredevils
commemorative markers or the models of
stunt errs and wax museums
I don't linger at the IMAX theaters
barrel exhibit I'm the proud purchaser
of postcards viewmaster reels and a
leather tie rack all bearing pictures of
the waterfall but while I bet you can
buy a pen with a miniature Blondin
inside sliding back and forth across
this tightrope I have never tried to
acquire one I know the stories you can't
miss them the town is rife with historic
markers recounting Daredevils and their
dubious accomplishments and
guidebooks are full of them to Blondin
is the most popular but there's also
Massachusetts mill worker Sam patch who
started it all in 1829 jumping into the
lower niagara from a platform between
the falls philadelphia Cooper Carlisle
Graham survived the Whirlpool Rapids in
a barrel he built himself unemployed
dancing teacher Annie Edison Taylor
became the first person to go over the
horseshoe in a barrel at the age of 63
Maude Willard suffocated in her barrel
because her dog stuffed his nose into
its air hole
George static has suffocated in his
after getting caught in the whirlpool
for 16 hours the turtle he took with him
survived there's the proof Roger
Woodward a seven-year-old boy was an
unwitting daredevil after a boating
accident in 1960 he went over the
Horseshoe and a life jacket and lived he
was the only person to survive an
unprotected trip over the brink until
2003 when Kirk Jones an unemployed
salesman of auto industry tool threw
himself drunkenly into the rapids and
somehow survives the plunge
as an aside I'm from Michigan and Kirk
is from Michigan
Annie's from Michigan the first shift
that they sent over the schooner that
went over the falls is called the
Michigan there's some kind of Michigan
connection with the Falls but I'm not
sure what it is
Niagara histories always treat such
performances and stunts with an odd lack
of wonder of course people want to go
over the falls in a barrel of course
tightrope walkers want to dare the
Niagara Gorge and of course readers want
to hear about who succeeded who failed
and whether the Turtle describes the
barrel ride afterwards as George static
is promised it would it didn't if you
think you detective superior tone you're
not far off I take pride in resisting
the allure of the Daredevils and I have
to admit it comes partly out of snobbery
that long tradition of insisting that
Niagara is gussied up with tawdry
spectacle but I'm really interested in
the Falls the claim is akin to the
Protestants of men who swear they read
playboy for the articles
I don't divert my eyes when I come to
mr. Graham
barrel but honestly it doesn't do much
for me I am interested in meaning and
daredevil stunts don't have meanings at
least not complex ones
they're simply about the desire of
certain individuals to make spectacles
of themselves by challenging nature and
what it has to be said are some pretty
dumb ways go over the falls in a barrel
who thought that up anyway or so I once
believed until I began to think about
Blondin one night at dinner I quit my
boyfriend Bob who was Blondin I demand
the tightrope guy he says right away Bob
bored of youth to these little Niagara
history Kornbluth he went across the
river at Niagara Falls granted bob has
an advantage he's been dragged to my eye
for multiple times has seen the IMAX
film Niagara missed miracles and magic
at least three times has been
conscripted onto the Maid of the Mist
and hauled under the waterfall at the
Cave of the wind and has suffered
through so many long stories that
commemorate in rocks scenic vistas and
tombstones he now declines all offers of
free trips to Niagara I had I had a bob
slide but I took it out but there bob is
in the back of the room if anyone wants
to lay eyes on him at home he managed to
muster a fake smile when he unwrapped
the waterfall tie rack at Christmas but
after being subjected to dozens of
horrible DVDs featuring the Falls he did
a search for Niagara Falls on the
Internet Movie Database and banned any
resulting films from our Netflix queue
when did Blondin cross I asked and Bob
looks baffled the turn of the century he
hazards
I let the topic drop Bob looks relieved
though later I find him shuffling
through the latest Netflix arrivals with
a nervous look as if one of the might
contain a bomb Blondin born
jean-francois gravel a may very well be
the best aerialist who ever lived his
two summers at my agra held america
captive with suspense as he made more
than a dozen crossings from the American
to the Canadian side of a Niagara Gorge
and then back again
thousands of people travel to Niagara
Falls to see him and newspapers
nationwide reported on his every move he
had a truly unmatchable act but was that
really enough to hold the nation
spellbound for two summers running
though summers were 1859 and 1863 as
views and pictures of London because
they're so great and I just kind of had
to cram them all in this one I think is
especially good the more I read about
London the more unconvinced his feats
over the Niagara River weren't just
spectacular
they plugged right into the national
mood and anxious and divided America
hovering on the brink of war worried
together for a small man walking on a
rope but even more what spectators were
seeing was a succinct reenactment of a
national spectacle all the more powerful
for being unseen America was transfixed
by a man's impossible journeys across
the very river slaves regularly crossed
to freedom performances were on
Wednesdays or Thursdays around 4:00 p.m.
a magnificent carriage would bear blond
into an American Park called White's
pleasure grounds from there he would
cross the tightrope to Canada performing
tricks and stunts along the way upon
arriving in Canada he would be taken by
carriage to Clifton house where he would
rest out before his journey back to the
States the overtones of a man taking a
dangerous journey from the u.s. to
Canada had to be clear for
african-americans Canada was synonymous
with freedom the British Emancipation
Act of 1833 had banned slavery in the
entire British Empire by blonde UNS
first performance more than twenty
thousand blacks lived in Ontario many of
them emancipated slaves travelers to the
area often visited their communities
remarking on the settlers
accomplishments in farming and education
an abolitionist published accounts such
as Benjamin Drew's oral history the
refugee published in 1856 in 1858 the
year Blondin came to check out the false
the radical abolitionist John Brown was
in Ontario organizing an abolitionist
convention visiting Harriet Tubman
in st. Catharines and collecting
volunteers for his planned raid on the
federal Arsenal at Harpers Ferry
Virginia these are the Underground
Railroad routes there were four main
routes into Canada fugitives could get
on a great lake steamship cross the
Detroit River Detroit River to Windsor
or hoof it from Quaker farm to Quaker
farm all the way to northern Vermont or
they could go to Niagara there at Black
Rock and Lewiston the river narrowed to
a manageable width and in 1848 an even
better crossing was completed Charles
Ellis suspension bridge quickly followed
in 1855 by John Augustus rolling
roebling's railway suspension bridge the
bridge was so well known as a crossing
point for fugitives that Harriet
Tubman's first biographer Sarah Bradford
simply refers to it as the suspension
bridge without bothering to name the
town how many people cross the Niagara
River to freedom is not known the
Underground Railroad worked because it
left so few traces that may also be why
the history of the Underground Railroad
in the Niagara region is far less
familiar than the history of stunting
Pierre Berton in his fat bestseller
Niagara doesn't mention it at all
geographer Patrick McGreevy who analyzes
the history of pilgrimage and utopia at
the Falls in his book imagining Niagara
says nothing about it
the official souvenir book from the
Niagara Falls State Park has whole
chapters dedicated to Daredevils and
honeymoons but says nothing about the
Underground Railroad in Niagara Falls
State Park you can find statues and
portraits of the porters Olmsted Nikola
Tesla and Chief Clinton Ricard founder
of the Indian defense league but you
can't find an image of Harriet Tubman
after the Fugitive Slave Act of 1850 the
plight of the fugitive slave went from
hidden ordeal to national drama popular
newspapers gave extensive coverage to
chilling tales such as the 1856 tragedy
of Margaret garner and here's a painting
of it
garner was a fugitive who on the verge
of being recaptured slit her
two-year-old daughter throat rather than
see her sent back into bondage Toni
Morrison later based her novel beloved
on this event in the 1850s blackface
minstrel shows began openly referring to
fugitives performing songs about
families torn apart and bondsman
determined to be free and in a literal
staging of the national spectacle
Harriet Beecher Stowe's abolitionist
novel Uncle Tom's Cabin burst onto the
scene in 1852 and was immediately
adapted many times for the theater
that's the frontispiece from an early
edition such as the state of the nation
in 1859 the Year Blondin chose to stage
his performances for his setting he
picked an American icon that happened to
be a symbol of freedom for slaves in a
town where frequent fugitive escapes
were reported with approval in the local
paper
Niagara chroniclers love describing
Blonde ins clever acts he crossed the
rope one day wearing a sack over his
head he pushed a wheelbarrow across
imitating a manual laborer he crossed
with an iron stove wearing a chef's hat
and set it up and cooked omelets Midway
which he passed down to the Maid of the
Mist below he crossed on stilts most
famously he carried hairy Colcord over
twice newspapers all over the nation
reported on each new performance always
declaring that Blondin couldn't possibly
surpass the latest feat exit from later
accounts as the acts historical context
but considered in the light of the
increasingly bitter slavery standoff and
of Niagara central role in that drama
the performances take on a different
tone when blonde and cooked omelets in a
chef's out that he had borrowed from the
head cook of the international he made
people think of the kitchens of Niagara
hotels which were filled with black
employees when he crossed with a stack
on his head he looked like a fugitive
being dragged back to slavery when he
crossed with Colcord on his back he was
within what we Michigan Ian's call
spitting distance or the very suspension
bridge across
which Harriet Tubman carried scores of
fugitives the crowds anxiety was all for
his passenger would blonde and get the
man across the most powerfully
suggestive performance was his crossing
of the tightrope wearing an iron collar
chains handcuffs and shackles this getup
was said to be the character of a
Siberian slave but it must have
suggested cruelties closer to home if
there was a universal symbol for slavery
it was a set of shackles and this was
that an abolitionist medallion
abolitionists were often photographed
holding broken ones and abolitionists
literature frequently included their
image that's the abolitionist Thomas
Johnson today the one material object in
the castellani art museums Underground
Railroad exhibit is a set of shackles
with a tag neatly engraved th Porter
dealer in horses and slaves Blondin
never made any public statements about
slavery or any other aspect of American
politics he was a performer here to
entertain folks and make a lot of money
but imagine magician David Copperfield
putting on a magic show somewhere in the
desert along the Mexican border imagine
he gets Regis and Kelly to come and tape
segments of the show in which he builds
a wall and make someone disappear on one
side of the wall and reappear on the
other then he has himself straitjacketed
locked in a box and dropped into the Rio
Grande say he has to escape his bonds
and swim to the other side Peggy does it
when the Senate is hashing out a new
immigration bill and immigrants are
marching in the streets demanding a path
to citizenship with people somehow get
the idea that this performance meant
something
in September of 1862 ond and performed
for the last time at Niagara two months
later the American people elected a new
president named Abraham Lincoln and
South Carolina promptly announced its
secession from the Union
Lincoln's win was a foregone conclusion
in the four-way race with a divided
Democratic Party not even voting for the
same candidate in north and south in
August 1860 well the aerialists were
still cavorting over the Niagara Gorge
Harper's ran a cartoon called the coming
man's presidential career this is it it
shows a bus blonde and in tight saris
lost my place
it showed a bus Blondin entice crossing
his wire with neat steps his grimly
determined face is not blond ins however
it's Lincoln's his balancing pole is
labeled Constitution and on the cliffs
behind him a sign with an arrow reads to
the whirlpool on his shoulders wearing a
smile that is half minstrelsy stereotype
half heart-rending portrait of Hope is a
barefoot black man the second line of
the caption reads motto don't give up
the ship history is frustrating we can
estimate the size of the crowd we can
look at catalogues to surmise that they
were wearing a train timetables to
deduce how they got there maybe we can
even find Bills of fare to tell us what
they ate that day but what they were
thinking remains a mystery
newspapers tell us the crowds were
silent their wide eyes fixed on Blondin
their faces tight with worry
what lurked behind that mask of
expectation where the abolitionists
among them secretly exulting in this
coded Rhapsody to freedom and the high
wire act it required were the
southerners in the crowd hoping the
Frenchmen would fall or did everyone
engage in a massive willing suspension
of disbelief agreeing for just two
summers to pretend the show was nothing
more than the crass sensational
spectacle so many critics denounced it
for
as the saying goes you can't dig up a
hole unfortunately history is full of
them
thank you that was a very shortened
section from that chapter and there's a
lot of other fun stuff in there that led
me to really become convinced that
Blondin performances were in fact about
the spectacle of fugitive slaves at my
aggress and i'm happy to take questions
from the audience we have our question
microphone getting ready to hear
technology makes our lives better and
easier a couple of questions one if
you're from Michigan and you then tell
us that until you told us about the
Drunken mission Lander who went over the
waterfall I don't know if there was a
correlation between drinking and
Michigan or something but why did you
choose Niagara Falls to write about and
the other question would be in Lincoln
caring you know I'm just blonde and
caricature that Lincoln's face was
placed on you said the thing was don't
give up the ship now these things are
colloquialisms that are trapped in time
I'm not clear as to what that means oh
and as an african american i thank you
for putting so much emphasis on that and
we're going to have to get with the
mayor who's in the back to make them
down it at the state parks put in the
official guys that you know the
Underground Railroad was a very
important part of what happened here and
I think that to go backwards through
your your your points which are all
wonderful and thank you for saying that
the region is certainly getting better
at telling the story of the Underground
Railroad
and what I wanted to do was put it
together with the Daredevils in a new
way the question of what led me to
Niagara I came to Niagara as a college
student
even though I grew up in the Great Lakes
region I never had actually been to the
Falls and I came with my college
boyfriend and we thought we'd have a
kitschy fun time and see you know stay
in a heart-shaped jacuzzi and maybe get
some kitschy souvenirs and stuff and I
stepped out of the car and I heard she
was one of those days when the waterfall
is really loud and I heard it and I was
just overwhelmed and it that started a
little flame in my head a little kind of
flicker of interest wow this place has
got something fascinating going on years
later I came back and toured the power
plant on the Canadian side and I learned
that the waterfall has hours of
operation as all of you know it's turned
up between the hours of 8 a.m. and 10
p.m. for the tourist season and turned
down at night to generate power and at
that point I was obsessed because I love
those kinds of contradictions I think
they're so interesting and that you know
the idea that this this giant and
overwhelming natural wonder that is
undeniably impressive when you see it
and a sign of something bigger than us
and grander than us is in fact under our
control that fascinated me and I had to
learn more and I kept coming back on
vacations and whenever I had free time
and sometimes driving between New York
and Michigan I would just happen to find
myself in my Agra Falls and eventually
people began to urge me to stop the
laboring point at cocktail parties and
just get down to writing a book so
that's how that happened and you had
another global loop
oh don't give up the ship harp Pro
abolition so I feel pretty confident
that that don't give up the ship was a
kind of little statement to Lincoln you
know follow through with us you know go
ahead it's going to be a tough everyone
knew that Lincoln was going to go out on
a wire and then it was not going to be
an easy crossing that he was going to
make and that he was in some way defying
what people thought of as the way the
world worked and
I think Harper's Harper's was trying to
throw their their little you know glove
into the ring and say we're behind you
interestingly there was another another
cartoon that Maureen Fenny at the
Niagara Falls Public Library found for
me one day which was printed in Vanity
Fair I think I may have it here yeah
same thing Lincoln has Blondin much more
well you know satirical he looks he
looks terrible his tightrope is a
rotting plank he's carrying the
carpetbag and there's this little doll
sized african-american fellow in it
Vanity Fair was anti abolition so they
were using the same motif to criticize
Lincoln and try to suggest he was you
know an idiot another question
you mentioned the ship Michigan I
believe the name of it was and I
forgotten the exact date perhaps 1836
around in that time 7 1826 and I
remembered it because it seems such a to
portray such a dark dark picture of
human nature and I wonder if you could
comment on the thousands of people who
came to see a ship load of animals go to
their death certainly fall certainly one
of the interesting things about the the
schooner Michigan which many of you are
probably familiar with but perhaps for
the benefit of the c-span audience all
say was a schooner that was gotten up as
a pirate ship filled with geese a
buffalo a couple of bears a dog and sent
over the Falls to its fate
which was an ugly fate in 1827 that was
a tourist an attempt to draw crowds to
Niagara Falls and see this kind of
spectacle of cruelty and thousands of
people did come I do talk about it a lot
in the book because you know that it's
it's it was always mentioned in
nineteenth-century guidebooks and as
this kind of wow this phone thing
happened in 1827 and now it's very
rarely mentioned and what it is
mentioned it's kind of brought up as
well here with the moment when crass
spectacle started to happen at the fall
and started to replace sublime natural
wonder this was the first offense one of
the interesting things I discovered in
researching the book is that the porters
Peter Porter and Augustus Porter the
town fathers were intimately involved in
that spectacle they helped to stage it
the ship used to belong to Peter Porter
the navigator who sailed it was actually
a friend and an employee of Peters and
Augustus wrote to Peter asking him to
send the big steam ships full of
tourists to the American side rather
than the Canadian side during that day
so that American Canadian rivalry was
already in place in 1827 I found it
fascinating that people
in a funny kind of way created this
almost symbolic moment you know here's a
ship called the Michigan and the
Michigan territory is just being settled
at this moment when the Michigan was
sent over the Falls and it's filled with
flora and fauna from the the Upper Great
Lakes and sent over the Falls it's
almost as if they're staging the
spoiling of nature that's getting
underway with the settling of Michigan
that was intriguing to me and well for
the rest L I'll leave the rest for for
the book thank you for the question I'm
glad you brought up the Michigan because
it's one of the more interesting moments
well let's let this lady have a choice
thank you for this book it looks
beautiful I haven't had a chance to read
it yet but one of the areas that I'm
very interested in is the beginning of
electrical transmission and Tesla and
Westinghouse I'm sure you must cover
part of that in here yeah talk a little
bit about that miracle yes the
electrification of Niagara of course
happening around 1895 one of the one of
the more fascinating things that I found
out as I was digging through that
history was that many of the gentlemen
of Free Niagara Olmsted's movement to
save the fall from commercialization and
turn it into America's first state park
and let people see it for free take down
all of the fences and commercial
attractions that people had put up right
around the Falls that movement was
funded by the same gentleman who then
went on to found the Niagara Falls power
company and harness the Falls the man
who drew the map of the what is to this
day that the boundary of Niagara Falls
State Parks Thomas Evershed was the
engineer for the Power Company and he
stopped the State Park right at the
point of the hydraulic canal so that was
intriguing to me the renature of Niagara
and hand in hand with the harnessing of
the waterfall for power and I look at
the ways in which the the waterfall
almost became a sort of spokesmodel for
electricity because people were very
dubious about electricity when it first
started to move around or be spread out
through people's homes a lot of people
didn't want to sign up for it especially
because Edison was going around
electrocuting dogs and you know giving
it a bad name Niagra helped people kind
of get it and see it as something
something not so harmful and something
good for the environment and the the
press about it constantly said this this
is the source of power that's limitless
it has no influence on the environment
whatsoever it's just you know it has no
downside and you see this in these early
20th century ads for electric appliances
which were of course made by the very
same people who are generating and
selling the power they wanted you to buy
lots of electric appliances they would
have an ad that would show a sort of
here's an electric typewriter and in the
background would be Niagara Falls it was
it was like it's just a great big
waterwheel you know we're going to we're
going to change change our lives without
without having an effect on nature and
of course hydro is relatively benign and
I'm a fan of hydroelectricity but it
does have an effect and I'm I'm in favor
of having a clear-eyed vision about what
those effects are so thank you for that
question I think there was list there
the microphone traveling hello history
teacher 9 Falls High School I'd like to
know if it'd be possible just to talk
about the I think you did some research
on the nuclear industry in Niagara Falls
and in the 50s if we could just talk
about that for sure sure I'd be happy to
that was one of the really surprising
things to me when I started hearing
things from from locals about this I was
I was amazed I had no idea that a lot of
the Manhattan Project unfolded at
Niagara Falls this happened because of
the harnessing of Niagara the one thing
leads to the next and leads to the next
and my agra produced so much cheap
electricity
as you all know that the
electrometallurgical and electric
chemical industries came to town and
created a very vibrant and exciting
industrial place that was at the
forefront of America's chemical industry
and also aluminum and other other metals
when Leslie growths began the director
of the Manhattan Project began looking
for places to refine and roll uranium he
went to business associates he had in
Niagara Falls and Niagara Falls had the
capacity to do this one of the fatter
parts of the story is that the gentlemen
who actually did their refining and
rolling of the uranium weren't told what
they were doing and that was that was
very surprising to me as I found that
out and talked to some of them and it's
an amazing story people coming to the
Falls today I think many aren't even
cognizant of the incredible industrial
background of the Falls the fact that
really industry was customer number one
throughout most of the 20th century and
tourism came in second and the Manhattan
Project side of it is even more I think
were less well known so that that's a
very interesting part of the story and
one of the things that I thought was
important to work back into the to tell
again even even to tourists I think it's
fascinating the fascinating part of the
history of the town and you know they M
there there's been talk of making a
national park about you know the atomic
legacy of the United States and they're
looking at Los Alamos of course and Oak
Ridge and possibly the Hanford Nuclear
Reservation but I think there's good
reason to put Niagara Falls on that list
too and most tourists would find it
fascinating yes hi I was wondering if
you caught some of the UH darker issues
that involve this city like uh like he
was saying the UH
nuclear radiation there is new law
reports that they mix it in with the
road systems around here and there's
radioactive hot spots around here there
is also the way it is the state park is
set up they bring everybody into the
State Park charge them ten dollars for
parking trying to spend their money on
Tomatoes a mess then ship them right out
of the city it's a very disappointing
fact that they don't bring anybody into
the actual city itself there's also
things like Love Canal and budget like
the power project how they stole land
away from the Indians make the reservoir
I was just wondering if any of this was
in your book it is indeed yes oh that's
in fact I went to the Robert Moses
papers at the New York Public Library
and found out a lot more about the
Moses Tuscarora standoff which I thought
was very interesting and talked to
people about that and talked about the
environmental legacy with the help of
many wonderful activists in town and and
many EPA reports in fact I live in lower
Manhattan and my apartment was recently
tested for lead by the EPA and the guy
who was consultant EPA consultant was in
the apartment testing lead and somehow
Niagara Falls came up I don't know it
just happened with me and he said oh
yeah I did a report up there I wrote the
EPA report for the Forest Glen
subdivision and I said oh my god I love
your work I read that report and he was
kind of he was going who is this woman
but yeah I try to work it all in and of
course my my book is a survey of you
know many hundreds and hundreds of years
of history and I really kind of grazed
the surface and and raised a variety of
issues trying to see them all in the
context of our relationship to nature
and then I think that there are plenty
of other people who are going to who are
get
more detailed and doing more detailed
work on these issues are if you look
across the L river you can see the a big
beautiful thing if you come over here we
got Pine Avenue and this beautiful place
the corner not too fair how do you think
we would uh we should improve this city
I think that there are many many
positive things going on in my Agra
Falls I think that and I was talking
with radio host a couple days ago
actually and it was a call-in show and a
woman called in and said I just want to
say that I was at Niagara Falls for the
first time I went I only went to the
Canadian side and the second time I went
I went to the American side and I want
people to know that you can't see my
Agra Falls without seeing both sides and
I think that's really true I think that
the Canadian side and the American side
complements each other in a way you do
have the panorama on the Canadian side
but on the American side you have Goat
Island you can get right up there on the
three sisters and really feel the force
of it and see what it's like and it to
me that there's nothing like that on the
Canadian side so I think it's essential
to come over here I also think that the
hiking paths in the gorge are stupendous
and you know well worth doing and I
would love to see more tourists going
down into the gorge and walking through
whirlpool State Park and Devil's Hole
State Park those are beautiful beautiful
spots that you don't even have to pay to
see so I think and I think that there's
a lot of awareness on the part of
planners today and local people today in
Niagara Falls but this is what Niagara
Falls has to offer it has a real
connection to the to the landscape in a
way that the Canadian side doesn't
necessarily have they have some other
kinds of attractions and and beautiful
gardens and a lovely bike path but here
it's a little a little more a little
Wilder and that's fun I think I think
you have to do both gentlemen back do
you talk about the political
expropriation of economic control of the
power no no I don't know enough about
that to talk about that and also
the story the power story there's so
much to say about the harnessing of the
waterfall and then you know going on the
the use of the waterfall in the in the
general and our general what I consider
somewhat careless use of power you know
that we that we really don't conserve
electricity as much as we possibly could
so that's more my more in my position I
was also aiming and writing this book to
reach a very broad audience to reach you
know people who are interested in
history all across the nation and so
many of those very local very local
issues I probably don't drill down as
much as someone else would who is
focusing on this region well would you
say that the theme of the book then is
though expropriation yes I would say the
theme of the book is the way we kind of
separate ourselves from nature and the
way we're constantly trying to impose
one of two simplistic views on nature
it's either unspoiled and perfect and we
don't touch it or it's spoiled and
ruined and we just use it up without any
regard for it and I think that what
Niagara helps us to learn is that we
need to have a more interactive
relationship with nature that we don't
just stand apart from it and look at it
we do use it it's so it's a waterfall it
has a lot of motive forcing there that
we can utilize but that we also need to
be aware of the environmental
consequences of what we do well you know
the professor the history teacher mr.
Esposito and Anne here you know they
think they brought out a very good point
from reading online what your book has
to say you know from your excellent web
page by the way thank you I sort of got
the impression that you were kind of
against industrial but now it seems to
me that you kind of recognize that had
it not been for alternating current
thing here in Niagara Falls the US
wouldn't be where we are
are the industrialization we would have
been in a very small hotel next to a
great big waterfall speaking German
today because the ecology industry here
was one of the big things that helped us
to win when the war and keep the world
see do you believe that there is a
balance between industry tourism and the
slogan that's been I agree father's for
over a hundred years a king of power
queen of beauty yeah and I titled my
chapter on power king of power - queen
of beauty because I believe that I
believe that that balance can be found
is it an easy process no it's not and it
takes a lot of public involvement and
constant soul-searching and thinking
about what we're doing and what we need
to do and I think that it's possible I
really and I believe that that process
is underway so thank you for that for
raising that point hello I like a thank
you for coming and I especially like
thank you for coming to the book corner
an authentic bookstore a locally owned
book scanner philately I'm prejudiced
I've been coming here since I was a
small child I loved the place loved the
cats the cats are spectacular I have
another Michigan Niagara Falls town our
high school team is called the
Wolverines they wear Wolverine colors no
yes oh that in addition the question I
wanted to ask um do you have any general
comments on the impact of mr. Robert
Moses now just in the American idea in
my opinion the combination of real
backed by capital that's a lot of our
culture a lot of our society and people
in now New York State know who Robert
Moses is not my personal opinion for a
long time he was more powerful than the
governor uh-huh I was just wondering if
you had any general statements tying in
with your general theme of expropriation
of the environment absolutely I mean you
put it very well we'll backed by capital
might be a great description of mr.
Moses himself he is certainly in New
York City you know he's everyone's
favorite villain we love to hate Robert
Moses because he put in highways in the
world's best walking City
and he you know did all sorts of dubious
things with the parks that that weren't
necessarily he built beautiful parks but
you know many of them weren't in the
right neighborhoods but in the
neighborhoods that needed the most and
things like that at Niagara Falls he was
of course a disaster you know a one-man
wrecking crew who came through town and
you know rammed that Parkway right
between downtown and the waterfalls and
and then you know when I had to try to
bulldoze over everybody who had any even
the slightest objection he was not a man
who brooked objection very well at one
point when I came across a letter and
the Moses files in the New York Public
Library that I couldn't believe it was
not about Niagara was about the st.
Lawrence Project but they were building
a reservoir there and they were going to
stock it with fish and the reservoir is
on the American Canadian border and so
Moses was writing to his general
engineer asking how they were going to
make sure those fish stayed on the
American side but to me that just says
everything about this gentleman he is
determined to micromanage the fish you
know so what's he going to do when he
when he came across the river in New
York City that he didn't like he moved
in you know and when he came across
Niagara Falls he did what he wanted
there and so he's a very interesting
case study and luckily we don't we don't
have a Robert Moses today number of
families that were displaced by his
projects you know I don't know because
it's hard to find exactly those numbers
because the whole town was in such
upheaval when that happens because tons
of people came to town to work on the
power project and in a way all those
people were displaced because they would
they came to town to work on the project
the power project lived in the temporary
housing and then had to go elsewhere so
the town was just you know completely in
upheaval during that whole period you
know as I mentioned in the book that
there are two rumors about Robert Moses
that circulated Niagara County one is
that he came back and saw the Parkway
and said Oh shouldn't
laughs and the other is that he did it
out of revenge you know he did it
because he wanted to pay back the people
who were who obstructed him in his in
his work I don't know if either of those
is true I couldn't find confirmation
unfortunately so I just had to say these
are the rumors so other questions you
know just I hate to defend Robert Rosen
yes it's true there are say there are
good things to be said it's true but you
know when you start to look at those
Parkway I hate to defend Robert Moses
but when you start to look at those part
ways we moved we and I was this place I
was one of those displaced families as a
result of the Robert Moses our project
but you're moving all of that stone and
you have to put it someplace and you
can't plan any other kind of Road unless
you have that type of autonomy that
Robert Moses had in order to make broad
beds out of the stone so there's a
regionalization of what we were
extracting out of that Gorge and through
those two long tunnels that went from
the Upper River down to the for day in
which that stone from the Robert Moses
parkways came and also he extended out
into the riverbed I know some
environmentalists would be upset with
that but you had if you had to build
this project and you had to build it in
the time frame that it had to be built
you had to do something with aggregate
that you were pulling out of the ground
and that was part of the reason why he
built the roads now where he built those
roads it was just a matter of
convenience yeah well he also used a lot
of that fell to enlarge Goat Island that
was that was done with that originally
Goat Island was going to be enlarged all
the way back to the Grand Island bridge
which would have been weird whether we
got sufficiently American yeah good
point that's probably why I wanted to do
it
so are there any other questions or
anything I think we all want to thank
you ginger ginger strand has written for
several publications including Harper's
the Iowa review the believer and Orion
magazine where she is a contributing
editor she was a fellow in humanities at
Princeton University
miss strand is the author of flight a
novel for more information visit the
author's website at ginger strand
dot-com